hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast automation meet cell
separation presented by load ekaterina
kabak Raffi global product manager cell
separation Milton e biotech I'm Alexis
Krause of labyrinth and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lavage and
sponsored by Milton E biotech for more
information about our sponsor please
visit WWE biotech calm before it begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen once there's many
of your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and the
software is continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming load Academy
Dorothy I will now turn the presentation
over to her
good morning my name is Lester Ozzy and
I'm the global product manager for South
operation asthma Cindy biotech thank you
so much for the introduction - and for
the next 45 minutes or so I'll be
talking to you about automating cell
separation processes and what to
consider in this automation meet cell
separation webinar I'm very happy that
you've taken the time to join us but so
thank you for that today we'll cover
topics that have to do with automating
your South operation processes why
automate in the first place and what to
consider when you're purchasing
automation we looked will be looking at
the process overview and for example the
laboratory context that your instrument
will be going into we'll also have a
look at max cell separation which
includes the metric max technology and
the max automation and finally in the
end we'll have a look at customer
project scenarios in which will firstly
have a look at scenario 1 which is many
different cell types as a service more
of a contract research organization kind
of kind of scenario or maybe a cool
facility at an academic institution and
in scenario 2 we'll have a look at high
throughput cell separation from buffy
coat
so why do people automate all separation
processes the main reason most people
automate their lab is for improved
efficiency and higher throughput this
gives you time to work on other high
priority tasks that cannot be automated
but automation isn't just about higher
throughput it's also about
standardization and less user
variability and human errors in your
website of course data reproducibility
is also really important you get that
you have the same protocol every time
and so you get the same performance with
every separation of course documentation
plays a large role if you're looking at
lint integration and sample tracking of
course that's really good if you do need
to do it if you do need to troubleshoot
downstream and it's very good to know
what
where your samples the tracking of your
samples to have it of course reducing
downtime and reruns due to contamination
also improves efficiency and improves
user safety of course you have to
balance out these aspects against the
finances for example your budget and the
return of interest on investment which
is something that we'll be discussing
later on as well and also there are some
inner emotional pedals that you need to
consider as well and sometimes there is
there's a certain fear of automation and
a certain comfort in the old ways that
you you're used to doing things
so when I see or talk to customers about
automation I ask them to draw the entire
process from when the samples that are
in the lab to the final step in the
industry and the process and this is a
generalized
and a very simplified process that we
might have from PVC VNC generation to
cell counting to cell labeling and then
the separation and an allegory step in
at the end I really wish it were this
easy and normally I'd actually go on a
big whiteboard and add all the details
such as the number of samples the type
of samples and the volume but we'll
actually just use this as a simplified
example today once you have your
overview of the process add a detailed
timeline if you're not sure about the
time just start a stopwatch and take
notes next time you do this the timeline
should be accurate so that you're able
to judge things well and finally add a
third column for the manual effort that
it takes to run each set
so now have a look at the web the
workflow that you've put together
identify the biggest bottleneck that you
absolutely need to have automated the
one that's taking the most time and the
one that requires the most effort also
what other additional steps do you have
that could or should be automated in
your process
the next question is what are your
expectation what are your goals what do
you expect from automating the process
and this is something that we have
already from the first slide is it to
improve efficiency and throughput in
your lab or is it standardization or or
is you the safety mainly your main
concern and then would you expect from
the implementation of the Ottoman
automation is it off-the-shelf protocol
vs. Optima optimisation so do you want
something that is ready for you or do
you have time to spend some time
tweaking things and optimizing them for
you do you want a simple instrument or
complex automation that will cover
several steps and in this context we
also speak about specificity versus
flexibility so the more specific your
processes or your automation is and the
more steps it covers the less flexible
it will be to work on other work with
other things and cover more processes as
well
the next one is laboratory context who's
going to be running the instrument do
you have one or two lab professionals
who will be trained to run the
instrument or is it supposed to be
somebody are you if the plan to have
some users come in and use the use the
instrument or do you reportedly have a
multi-user lab where you have maybe 5 10
15 people who will use the instrument do
you mainly run just one or two routine %
processes or something new every day and
what are your future plans does the
instrument need to grow together with
the lab or are you implanting new
processes in the near future that you
need to take into account into
consideration and also is the goal to
transfer the process into the clinic so
of course this is something that you
would want to consider if that if your
goal is to have a clinical procedure at
some point and you're doing the basic
research or proof of concept for that
process
we mentioned return-on-investment
already briefly and I'd like to dive
into this a little bit deeper because
it's not worth it for us is a very
standard answer against automation the
obvious consequence of automation is
that you're probably save on personal
costs when you don't need to hire as
many people however sample reruns and
lost material also cost a lot of time
and there's not really a monetary value
that you can put on lost material or
confidence in your scientific result if
something does go wrong troubleshooting
is going to be easier when your sample
is tracked and finally if your goal is
translational as we've already discussed
then you'll save a lot of time
implementing the process when you can go
from research to GMP grade with the same
workflow
so we've now established the steps that
you want to automate as well as your
what your expectations are
so far we've concentrated on the
existing protocol however now that
you're shaking things up anyway by
adding you're resyncing things you might
as well explore some new options
here's your workflow from earlier and
what are the options that you have to
change this there may be some new
technologies and steps that challenge
the current workflow for example
straight home approaches offer faster
separations from blow products without
the need for density gentrification for
relief technology can be used for
releasable labeling of yourself and of
course something like pre enrichment
enables or improves your flow sorting or
analysis there maybe there are other
integrations that streamline processes
and reduce edit errors and of course
there's a testing and validation
technical support is of course very
important whether you're running demos
but of course also if you're
implementing new processes and new
workflows you're going to need somebody
from technical support to support you
with those build questions and of course
service contracts are there to reduce
instrument downtime
so now that we've established all of the
expectations and covered all of the
expectations and the reasons to automate
you will normally want to weigh these
against the budget that you have
available so consider the changes in
your workflow consider your arguments
and whether they've actually been met by
automating this process and what changes
this what the changes in your website
and we'll get to all of this in a little
bit more later
we're going to change course a little
bit now and get to know the max
technology before moving on to our
customers and reo
you
so cell separation with max max
technology is based on three factors the
max microbeads the column and a magnet
first the self-interest of live
magnetically labeled with the max
microbeads then the cells are separated
by by some placing them on the on the
column which is an inner magnet and the
negative fraction is depleted of the
label cells after that you take a column
off of the magnet and alludes to
positively lit selected cell fraction
this is called positive solution
isolation or depletion of unwanted cells
of course there's also the untouched
cell isolation variant where you label
everything that you are not interested
in and then collect the flow-through
from the column of course the column is
the main aspect of it really sets us
apart from other technologies so let's
have a look at the column in a little
bit more detail the column is there to
amplify the Earth's magnetic gradient by
ten thousandfold what does this mean so
here on the left you can see a few
columns and on the right you can see how
the spheres in the column amplify the
gradient of the magnetic force this
ensures that we have a thorough magnetic
gradient throughout the column and this
enables minimal labeling with the nano
sized microbeads that we that we provide
it provides free flow through off the
cells through the column and thorough
washing for removal of cell debris and
contaminants
so in conclusion the max columns enable
cell separation with minimal effects on
the cells
of course this can be done manually but
also Milton anemic biotech offers
automated solutions for every need
whether if we look at sample throughput
fast with the level of automation on the
y-axis and the number of samples program
on the x-axis first we have the
automatic probe which is a magnetic
sales operator fully automated so high
up on the y-axis then it's designed for
1 to 6 samples in one run
going from 1 to 24 sample we have the
multi Maxwell 24 separator plus however
it's only semi-automated there's quite a
bit of manual type of things that you're
going to need to do and this is
available for 1 to 24 samples of our
bench and in order to make sure that we
have the high high end or high
throughput revolution also in fully
automated we just brought out the
multi-max X last year so this is an
instrument that integrates the multi-max
cell 24 separator into a liquid Hansa
it's fully automated and can process 1
to 24 samples in one run
if we then move on to a different kind
of comparison this time we're looking at
the sample volumes rather than
throughput we start on there on the left
with 200 microliters moving on to up to
200 milliliters on the right and the
automatic row can be used to separate
from 250 microliters took for 45
milliliters of blood products
the multi-max sensitive product family
can be used for small small volumes but
of course because we have the column
block and we have a parallel style
separation we're able to go much higher
volume for example the multi-max style
24 frets separator will go to about 100
100 millimeters before it might get a
little bit inconvenient and after that
the multi-max text with the fully
automated cell processing is quite able
to turn to process 200 milliliters
without without much hands-on at all
so this was a small overview of the max
technology so let's switch to the custom
s in iOS now
and process customer science we have a
busy lab with three main types of
one with human blood samples of three to
eight milliliters one with dissociated
mouth tumors and one with fuzzy coat
body code workflows contains a sample
preparation steps to generate deviancy
after which each each workflow has a
South operation step after the
separation the cd4 T cells of webstore
one and the cd45 tails of workflow to
are stained with antibodies and used for
a slow sort or flow analysis and the NK
cells from workflow three are used to
perform functional
and additionally one or three times a
month they have larger projects of 50 to
100 samples
now obviously this is a really busy job
so it makes sense
for their expectation for automating
their processes
Tivoli automation of sample labeling and
sales operation just take the hands off
just to reduce the hands on time
compatibility with as many sample types
as possible because of course as you
remember we had TDM speeds we had Mouse
dissociative tissues and we had and we
had whole blood
also higher sex ability with labeling
strategies reagents and methods is
really important because of course
there's a lot of different sample types
that need to be processed in different
ways
compatibility with flow sorting analysis
is also important because it's used in a
lot of sedans
and finally the user and process the
samples themselves or hire particular
assistance or health when they come in
to come into the courses
so
when we talk about flexibility and when
we talk about many different sample
types as not a biotech we think of the
automatic row these are the automatic
row highlight and they are firstly
infinite sample options secondly walk
away automation and one color fits all
in essence it's a really intuitive and
easy to use automation for a multi-user
lab
you have sequential separation of one to
six samples per run
you have a large variety of different
sample types and application even within
that one run so whether it's associates
Mouse tissue or its human whole blood
we're going to be able to combine
different in in one run
and you have to walk away automation
with automated magnetic labeling and
separation of yourself
and columns are actually reusable for 14
days with high cell capacity
so they're very well adjusted for their
work very well suited for this kind of
small teeny sample kind of workflow
of course what's also important to this
for this this scenario when when we
think about the important features for
this lab compatibility with flow is
crucial
and because the max microcut technology
allows minimum labeling of the cells the
epitopes are freely for later safety
procedures and this is shown on this
slide if you compare the top spot so the
top part of the South operation of the
team where you'll see there the max
pollen based health operations and the
bottom part of the picture with some
pollen free technology you'll see that
the minimal labeling that you have with
the map technology enables you to stain
saying the separated cells afterwards
using flow analysis compared to the
column-free technology where you have a
lot of slot types of epitopes due to the
massive labeling that you are you're
actually blocking a lot of these
epitopes that you will make the lasers
need for us or for staining and as you
can see in on the right-hand side if you
compare the upper and the lower but
you'll see that you have a lot of cells
that you're able to sing
when you get on the cd45 positive cells
whereas compared to the bottle lower
picture you don't really see anything at
any cells on the on the on the plot
because they can't be seen
so now we can have a look at the
expectations that the customer has and
compare them to do to my first afraid
firstly automation of sample sample
handling and cell separation
I think we can check that one off it's a
fully automated process compatibility
with as many cell types as possible also
here it's compatible with blood TV mcs
and dissociative tissues we also have
the high flexibility with labeling
strategies and reagents such as vo2 max
pro is virtually is compatible with
virtually all life's microbeads and
isolation tips also the compatibility
with slow sorting and honest and element
analysis is important
so max microbeads were developed for use
with flow cytometry and minimal labeling
leave depth of three-sustaining without
and the instrument is ideal for a
multi-user lab because it's so intuitive
and easy to use that anyone can just
come in and start
but then they did mention something else
they mentioned that they have a couple
of times a month largest larger sample
numbers
so for this we would recommend
additionally for the scenario one for
these larger projects product project
the multi-max cell 24 separator which
means easy handling of large sample
numbers for sample volumes
it's scalable so the sample throughput
fits every web flow from one to twenty
four samples in one run you can use the
24 Magnus
as individual magnets for small samples
for as one
for collage for examples such as the
vicar
and it's semi-automated which is
completely fine if you're running to
work so only once or twice
so this is something that would
definitely be useful for this scenario
also and now that we've discussed
scenario one and found the matches for
fullest workflow let's have a look at
the next customer where we have
high-throughput isolation of these
salads
let's have a look at the web so again
and I think you'll recognize this
this is the one that you saw earlier
degeneration cell counts ravening the
separation and adequate of the cells
afterwards
this takes well over two hours with a
major chunk of the time going into the
PDS new generation
affection is the density gradient
centrifugation with with densification
sets with cell counting steps and having
to wait for the centrifuge without a
break so this is something that firstly
takes a lot of time is very hands-on and
cannot be automated
so let's take a look at their
expectation
they are expecting to have a fully
automated sales operation of details
from buffy coat as little hands on his
work in the entire workflow as possible
because they are running this in hi
toothless and they want high viability
and functionality of the cells because
they're doing functional assays
afterwards and of course it needs to be
fast because this is a heightened
well firstly let's we'll have a look at
the main pay points which is the PDS
degeneration apparently the protocol
looks like this you have the buffy coat
using sensitive radius notification
which is the two-hour steps that you
have then you have your PBMCs and then
you run the map files operation
again taking flowers altogether however
using the straight from microbeads
you can go directly from your blood
product through the Maxwells operation
without without any density gradients
without cell counting and no washing
after labeling the straight from
microbeads are available for holes are
for buffy coat and for LRC's and silica
packs my straight from Lucas Park
microbeads are also coming
you can actually see that for
functional assays you're going to want
the cells as viable and as functional as
possible as we've already seen we have
this minimal labeling of the cells using
the max Mykleby technology due to the
columns which enables a high gradient of
magnetic force so here on the left you
can see a star that was isolated using
using Mac's microwave technology and on
the right you can see a star that was
isolated using a column critical here of
course you don't have the low gradient
the high gradient of magnetic force and
you have mastered labeling of the cells
and of course the question remains how
do these these these speeds and this
mustard labeling influence the
downstream applications that you're
going to do
also there's another example of celeb
activation so these are human be cells
that were isolated using Mac technology
and a colony method as you can see on
the on the left
before activation before separation and
then the cells were monitored
directly after separation seven days
after start after separation seven days
after separation and activated after
seven days of activation
the one son is going to be directly
after separation the one with the two
stars is going to be activated or
stimulated for these cells and the one
with the three stars is seven days after
cell separation and then in the middle
one is the max technology and on the
right one you'll see the column through
each method and this was done using or
measuring DD 69 CD 18 and CD 86 as
designed for activation market and as
you can see that with with ourselves
isolated using in fact technology there
is hardly any activation directly after
separation for seven days after seven
days of Culture also in the quality
method you don't see much as activation
directly after separation however after
seven days of culture there is a very
strong signal of activation which is of
course something that might influence
your activation acid which is something
that little box for each separation
so if we want to if we want to automate
these high high quality with cell
separation we can go for the multi max
set because this is the perfect
instrument for this demanding high to
fit cell for a sipping glass it has
fully automated baffle and buffer
handling and magnetic savings it has an
integrated multi-max dealt with
so 24 separate applause and a liquid
handler as you can see in this picture
ideas us both both of the blue boxes are
the vacuum station and the multi Maxwell
24 separator and it has an integrated
liquid handler which services the
multi-max as separate separation unit
you have faster fruits at separation
from many sample compiler for one large
sample and every application is
customized to fit your needs
so if we have a look at the protocol
that we have people and compare it to
the one that we will have with the
multi-max X together with the stray from
life will be
so first you would fill up the sample
the públicos 280 milliliters then label
the cells from the separation on the
multi-max X and then aliquot spouses as
needed
the time needed for this is just in the
60s including daily cooking set
the efforts that you need that is needed
is filling up the sparkle to 80
milliliters which is quite easy and all
of all the sets that come after us after
we automate
so you actually cut down your time from
two hours for over two hours to just one
hour and automated most of the most of
success and reduced your efforts suggest
minimal number minimal amount
so if we now have a look at the
expectations that we had fully automated
cell separation and our the multi my sex
cells
yes of course the process is now fully
automated you want to dilute little
hands-on work in the entire work so as
possible which is of course which we of
course you do have because the labeling
the cell separation and the allocating
are performed by these
of course the straight from microbeads
enables skipping sanctification
you also need high viability and
functionality of yourself which you have
because we have just seen that we have
no activation prior to the simulated
priority simulation ourselves and fast
processing time this Draper microbeads
shortened the first time in less than 45
so now we've seen
in to customer scenarios how I would be
max with any automation and instruments
and work together with the requirements
that different kinds of flaps might have
before sometimes you might have one
workflow and depending on the needs and
their expectations of the customer you
might end up with the exact same
workflow and still do differences and
that's why especially when we bring in
these new technologies it's so important
to have the technical sales consultants
and the application specialists because
they're able to tell you and inform you
about all of these new technologies and
new processes that we have available
and this spring speech my summary
self-suppression can be automated to
improve throughput and efficiency
reproducibility and standardization
you should consider the entire sample
process and identify crucial bottlenecks
when evaluating automated solutions and
new technology options and shorten
processes the Technical Sales hundred
consultants and application specialists
are a valuable source of information
here
and miss any biotech provides automation
solutions for every laboratory side
and with this I'd like to thank you for
your time and thank you for joining and
let's see if we have any questions
you
Thank You Lodha for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is is the protocol
the same for LROC and Luco pact the
protocol is going to be the same for
LRC's and Luco packs it depends a little
bit on the starting material so with
Buffy codes we start by filling the
sample up to 80 milliliters with LRC's
which we fill up to 40 milliliters and
with with lucre packs we fill up to 200
milliliters
but essentially from there the process
is exactly the same you add microbeads
you separate the some samples over a
certain number or type of columns so
from the leuco pack for the luka back
it's going to be the multi 224 column
blocks because of course you have higher
volume so it's going to be actually 24
columns that you're going to be using
for that for the LRC's we're using the
LS column and for the Buffy codes we use
whole blood columns and the columns are
actually included in the kit for all of
these for all of these sample types so
you don't have to worry about which kind
of column to use the reagents and the
the columns are actually included in the
kit
our next question is can i isolate mouse
bone marrow on the multi-max x and it is
possible to isolate themselves from mass
tomorrow and we don't it's not something
that we have a protocol for currently
but since every application is
specifically customized for for your
needs it's something that we would
specifically program according to your
workflow so we would just have to make
sure that our application development
team was was involved which is something
that they that they do and we have the
team here in-house at at baggage black
bar in Germany and they run all the all
the tests and make sure that that the
the results are exactly as you expect
them that the instrument and the
application fits exactly to what you're
doing
our next question is how long does the
separation of four samples on the auto
box Pro take that would depend on the
type of samples and what kind of
workflow you're running and of course
the auto max Pro has several different
program types so it would depend on that
it would depend on what kind of sample
it is whether you're going for something
that requires only one column to be used
or two columns so we have on the auto
max Pro we have the possibility to use a
double column program which is actually
really useful because the columns are
reusable so you're not wasting so to
speak any columns by running it through
two columns and you have additional
purity with these steps so it's actually
really difficult to say how long that
would take it would require it we would
need to know what kind of samples you
were running and what kind of protocol
you wanted whether you were looking for
higher purity or higher recovery so due
to the - due to the flexibility that we
have on the auto max you can either go
for a faster faster separation or a spot
slightly longer one with with a double
column program
some Mota looks like we have time for
one more question
how many Buffy coats can I process in
parallel
it depends on the instrument and the
kind of protocol that we're running
normally one buffy coat is processed in
one run using 12 columns however it is
also possible to run it to run possibly
more buffy coats in in one run so that's
something that we would then again
discuss with our application development
team and something that we would have to
program on the multi-max x so that's
that's definitely something that would
have to be discussed again and looks at
look at all of the needs but in general
the kits are specified for one buffy
coat is one kit and one run
I would like to Leslie
think Lotus for her presentation I would
also like to thank Milton E biotech for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2018 you always save
an email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye